that's how they all laugh
every single one of these guys everybody
screams and laughs
[ __ ] money money money
oh god yeah
i'm ryan [ __ ] right and i'm jerry
welcome to reasons to see we're gonna
give you some reasons to see
and not to [ __ ] see the wolf of wall
street
so let's hang the [ __ ] out
reason to see number one leonardo di
[ __ ] cabrio so we just saw the wolf
of wall street
yeah just now yeah the longest movie
ever made but yeah you know who i think
really makes this movie
obviously leonardo da [ __ ] caprio he
owns
this film he is the wolf in my personal
opinion
doesn't have to be yours but in my
best performance of the year if there's
one thing you can say about dicaprio he
puts it all out there yeah you go all
out you finally get to see some
sex scenes with dicaprio scenes multiple
sex scenes there's a
dicaprio i mean dicabro the whole time
he's doing a [ __ ] ton of drugs
he's so many drugs he's fooling around
with a ton of people
he's just a [ __ ] insane guy man he
embodies the role man he just he had
he went all out with this movie like
he's done things that you've never seen
dicaprio do before
yeah it's no holds barred in every sense
of the word and uh yeah he's still sexy
still sexy it's got a little chubby over
the ears a little slight chub
very slightly chubby just just in his
face
i really noticed i noticed it over the
years reason to see number two
jonah hill and you know jonah hill i
gotta say
very impressed with his performance in
this film and everyone gave him a lot of
kudos for moneyball but in this film
like
he you don't remember you're watching
jonah hill the entire time yeah
he's this guy throughout the whole film
he's very very
believable and you're not distracted by
the fact that jonah hill you just buy
this guy
you know moneyball came out he got
nominated and everyone was like yeah
he's good but it's not
anything nobody else could have done
this movie basically sees jonah hill
come in and be like no
no i can [ __ ] act okay yeah and like
he proves that he's fantastic as well
you know
and he and dicaprio play off each other
really well and he's a
character but he's still believable you
know and he's a jew
a damn good jew yeah he's certainly a
jew
yeah they don't quite establish wasp at
least yeah they don't quite establish
that he's jewish but you know he's he's
i'm pretty sure he's jewish he's reason
to see number three
the supporting [ __ ] cast this whole
cast is great all around you know and i
really like john bernthal in case you
guys know he is he played
shane on the walking dead he's the lead
in mom city i think he's [ __ ] cool i
mean he doesn't have that many scenes in
this film but there's enough to showcase
his talent and he
i totally i really enjoyed watching i
mean he's kind of that
muscular kind of sexy machidsmo kind of
fella a bunch of people you recognize
whose names i can't really point to
dicaprio's two wives in this film both
of them are very good and the wife
oh my god the second wife the blonde one
yeah
wow yeah holy mother of god i mean the
first time you see her naked you're just
like
damn [ __ ] they went there she is
really like naked like i'm talking
crotch and everything boy
i would love still to touch myself to
her the whole supporting cast is great
everyone's very authentic it's the kind
of acting and with a lot of these
characters and you walk away thinking
i didn't realize just how real everyone
was in this movie jean de jardin popped
up too i was happy to see him from the
artist
oh yeah and so did john favreau yeah
john favreau too
they really needed him for that role the
guy from uh friday night light show and
uh
yeah yeah he's he's really good in the
role too as the fbi agent trying to take
down the wolf of wall street
recently to see number four matthew
mcconaughey
and matthew mcconaughey manny mccartney
yes
yes he's he's got like a good ten
minutes of screen time but
he shines in those ten minutes man have
you ever known his he has very squeaky
s's nah never knows every time he says
letter s it's squeaky go back and watch
it it's so cool how he's like barely in
the film but he makes such a
mark on the screen you know and he looks
really weird in this film he's like
tanned
and really skinny his face looks like
whoa
he's aging kind of funny but you know
he's a method actor now he just
keeps losing weight and gaining weight
then getting buff again and that's just
the way mcconaughey rolls in well it's
probably because of dallas buyers club
too though because they i don't imagine
they probably film too far apart
i don't imagine that either jerry you
know there's a lot of things i don't
imagine
really yeah like monkey sex who needs to
think about that you just did
i didn't think about it i mean the words
came out of my mouth but the actual oh
there's the image reason to see number
five
ma martin scorsese you know we haven't
talked about yet
martin scorsese martin scorsese marty
jurassic park minority report saving
private right he's fantastic man
great director really different from his
other films you know
like e.t martin scorsese has not had any
trouble
staying current and relevant and
snappy scorsese is probably the most
consistent director we've ever had like
if you go on rotten tomatoes and just
look at all his films
like most of them like 95 of them are
just like highly recommended man and in
this film he does a great [ __ ] job he
knows how to just immerse you into this
crazy chaotic greedy world you know that
just
escalates and just gets more diabolical
and more excessive
and more debauchery yeah just it's like
a non-stop
thing of like okay i guess it's pounding
down up now we're we're going more
berserk again i think this is the kind
of film that i'm gonna like the more i
think about it and the more it like it
settles in because when you just walk
out of it it's like you got a lot to
absorb in three hours
yeah because it's a journey and it's
hard to do a three hour film and keep it
this consistently entertaining
throughout
i got the same uh sensation as i did
watching spring breakers where it's like
you you're eating too much cotton candy
it's like there's so much decadence and
so much excess
and so much going on that after a while
you're like
it kind of reminded me of like good
fellas i feel like this is the
goodfellas version of wall street
especially like with the narration and
stuff i thought the narration was
some of the best narration i've ever
seen in a movie too a white-collar
version of spring breakers meets good
fellas with
judd apatow style editing like that's
what this movie is
reason to see number six the writing
the writing's pretty solid too i mean
it's this is a hard film to structure
and this is a hard story to put together
so you need a solid [ __ ] script for
something like this and i don't know how
much the dialogue was improvised it
seems like there's some improv
if not i mean the dialogue is great in
so many ways
and it's the way the characters are all
written like they're everyone
has their own kind of unique voice even
if they're a minor character
even if they're similar they still have
a uniqueness about them
this is a true story or at least a
partially true story so you know that
things aren't going to turn out quite so
well by the end of it
yeah i mean the first two thirds of it
are the parts where things are still
going well for these people so it's
still
fun but then things
you know things [ __ ] gets real the last
third of the movie so that's the part
where you're like oh god
reasons not to see it's a bit too long
yeah everyone was talking about the
length of this film i i know the
original cut was four hours long i would
actually like to see that i think that'd
be interesting
to watch at the end of the day even
though it's three hours they managed to
cut out an hour every scene in this
movie is entertaining
like every scene they have is good but
when you look back on it and even while
i was watching i was like
that kind of was pointless to have 15
minutes of this stuff you know like one
specific thing that comes to mind is
this polar deal that deals with a gay
butler there's like
15 minutes of storyline that has really
nothing to do to advance the story in
any way inconsequential
yeah there's still some stuff that was
like that could have been trimmed down a
little bit
more but overall that is a bit too long
you know
i felt like they could have cut it down
like 20 or 30 more minutes to be honest
it's a bit over long for what it is i'd
still be interested to see a four-hour
cut for some reason just to see what
else was there
every scene except for maybe that
storyline every scene is good every
scene you know is
is engrossing but there are certain
scenes that just sort of go on a while
and you're like okay i get it
it's like there's so much of them like
partying in this film
sometimes like okay i get it they like
to party everywhere they go
from a formal po standpoint i understand
why they show you
so much of that stuff because part of it
is
going no no look at it like look at this
it's just that sometimes it gets a
little bit long-winded for me
just from an audience standpoint it was
like i don't really
need to see more of dicaprio [ __ ]
more chicks and doing more blow and
taking more prescription pills like
yeah i get it it's like it was already
excessive and then it was like
this now very excessive yeah it gets the
point across
most certainly it's like it does make me
go like i i don't
think that's the life i want to live
yeah i mean i thought it was going to be
one of those movies where i was like
am i going to walk out of this feeling
like i don't want to be like this guy
yeah no
no you don't you don't want any of this
you just don't want it it looks
horrible ryan's consensus another solid
film from dicaprio and scorsese
is the reason to see the wolf of wall
street another solid film from dicaprio
scorsese is the reason to see
the wolf of wall street yeah you know
these guys are just on a [ __ ] roll
the movie may be a little bit too long
but it's certainly entertaining and
dicaprio goes a powerhouse performance
jerry's consensus an entertaining
excessive epic is the reason to see the
wolf of wall street an entertaining
excessive epic is the reason to see the
wolf of wall street
you know it's crazy and off the wall and
batshit in a lot of ways and
it puts it all out there and goes look
at this all right guys who's checking
our review for the wolf of wall street
why don't you go ahead and scroll that
comment box below
and tell us if you had a [ __ ] ton of
money what would you do with it oh boy
and then once you're done with that why
don't you come over here click this
button so you can see more episodes of
reasons to see
and if you want to get updated every
time a new video of ours is out
subscribe do it man
[ __ ] do it oh boy boy this movie is
just a heart attack waiting to happen
i was just like wondering when all these
people were gonna drop dead yeah
like that guy's going to get liver
problems this person's going to
od that's right no no deed in this film
i know i was so waiting for it to happen
hey everyone's on a [ __ ] tonight
somebody almost
chokes but nobody actually almost od's
yeah man
yeah i mean i don't know if i would
do cocaine out of a girl's butthole no
he was
blowing it was blowing it into the black
yeah i mean he also got the candle in
his butt
yeah i don't know that just looks really
painful yeah
oh but you know whose ass i would blow
cocaine into his uh second wife
she's pretty hot i would be more than
happy to do that
tell me how that goes i would do many
things to that person's butthole
thanks yeah i wouldn't i don't want to
picture that you know some people really
do the whole gerbil thing in their butt
do they yeah i think that's really
disgusting
it's like a live little rodent inside of
your butt like why
why would you do that it just doesn't
make any sense how do you know this
i don't know it's a real fetish but you
know i think there's some porn that
actually does it too
oh
no i'm not
you tell you what i'm gonna look up that
porno yeah
and i'll tell you if i was able to
masturbate to it
you